you know we we found a clip this is you
actually interviewing your father
remember driving home with you to na a
number of times and talking the whole
time because you'd never stop asking
questions yeah well hasn't changed much
I think I remember mostly when I was a
little kid reading with you oh yeah yeah
well that was great that was so much fun
I thought
so I can see how moved you are Jordan
understandably I have no remorse for
this man it's a very sad situation where
he's lost his father but we have to
understand Peterson is a very evil
individual and he appears Morgan is
humanizing his father which is good
thing to do but why can we not humanize
the Palestinians why are they just
numbers
40,000 zombie scrolling is making you
dumber depressed and killing your
spirituality join the zombie scrolling
course so you can learn the three steps
to take charge of your
lifeam brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inah I'm
here withed
we do our little mini classes here every
Thursday and also sometimes we react to
videos so if there's any videos you
would like us to react to please comment
it and every week Thursday we'll react
to it and Friday we'll release the video
inah in the meantime if you're zombie
scrolling like me you addict
crackhead tell us a bit about this
zombie scrolling zombie scrolling makes
you dumber depressed and it's something
that's killing your life goals because
you're focusing on instant gratification
rather than long-term success so join
the zombiie scrolling course and you
will turn your phone gray like Ali did
but then you stopped doing it I think
you're talking to me I felt that it
really Hur me so guys if you are
watching this there's a description in
the in the description box and the
comment section check it out inshah guys
it is a constant struggle but Get Up
Stand Up don't give up the fight that's
what Bob Mar said but anyways let's go
to what uh this little peasant is saying
was discovered that your father had died
several weeks ago and found an obituary
I don't I don't know whether you wrote
this obituary one of the family did and
it talked about Dad it's one of the I
wrote it it was you I thought it was
um because I read it and I found it
unbelievably moving I was going to leave
it to the end but since you've mentioned
it now first of all my deepest
condolences on losing a remarkable man I
mean even if I didn't know the
connection I just read this about
somebody I would think what a remarkable
life he had he had three children uh
four grandchildren he was a
great-grandfather to four more um he
grew up uh in Norway in a log cabin um
but then as he said he lived Outdoors
shooting hunting bird watching trapping
CrossCountry skiing canoeing and he was
an enthusiastic collector of sing shot
rifles I love this detail that he he
loved their Simplicity of their design
and craftsmanship more importantly he
loved the Precision of these rifles and
he liked the fact that a single shot
rifle only allowed for one bullet as a
hunter dead center and that that
epitomized to you the care and attention
that he put into his work and he was a
beautiful gunsmith and Craftsman uh all
of these things um and then became a
teacher and was quite a tough
disciplinarian you say here he could be
fearsome you know act acting up in W's
class was not the world's best idea and
as a result there wasn't much trouble
there that was definitely true but but
he loved kids too and he was great with
them and as I was reading all this bro
is it me look at his face he's literally
like and look I'll be honest with you
let's if we just said this little
poisonous individual Peterson he did not
make those statements about the the um
Palestinians telling netan to give them
help let's put that said let's act as if
that's never happened I would sympathize
with this he's reading and this this
more on his what P Morgan the way he's
emphasizing it but but look I I just I
do want to say something Al right look
at even like it's a very sad situation
where he's lost his father but we have
to understand Peterson is a very evil
individual and here appears Morgan is
humanizing his father which is good
thing to do but why can we not humanize
the Palestinians why are they just
numbers 40,000 50,000 that was my point
that's why I said let's just act as if
Piers Morgan never defended Israel
Peterson never said give them help let's
put that out of our memory that never
happened you will sympathize with this
you'll feel like your heart a bit a like
aching in the sense it's not my father
but I can hear How Deeply he's hurt
correct as a human being we would do
that and Islam tells us to sympathize
with people's emotions however very
bizarr like you said which is the point
here look at him describing his dad and
he was a shooter and he did this and
he's getting emotional look at the the
the the the the the the price they give
to life of a shall I say a Caucasian man
a a western man and the way he's
describing and the respect he gives
Andel out his selective outrage and look
at him nearly breaking down crying these
are normal human reactions the question
we're asking is the following as a human
being that is so upset about his own
father how can it be that you are seeing
what the Palestinians are going through
but you do not have the same reaction
both of them in fact you en you
encourage that type of action and we
have to remember something right someone
like him and you know he is somebody who
clearly does understand his own
influence he's an whether we like it or
not he's one of the most influential
people on the planet now someone like
him giving a blanket statement like give
them hell what is he basically doing he
is creating a situation where it's like
give them hell it's it's part of that
that narrative that okay it's all about
self-defense and this and that and we
know before October the 7th what the
hell were these is doing to the
Palestinian for years he was quiet he
went and he he look he he can't be so
naive that he doesn't know what was
happening he can't be so naive that he's
not giving a blank uh if you like check
to the Israelis in terms of oh you have
my full support and after that point did
he come out and say how can you level
hospitals how can he level schools how
can you level mosques how can you kill
children how can he kill women this
conflict so many journalists were killed
so him and Murray and all these other
shills they are openly selling
themselves to Israel and do you know
what he's lost a lot of support of
course he do even he lost support before
then but that moment he lost a lot of to
to me we're going to carry on watching
it guys to me it's like Hitler not
having remorse of the people that he
killed or should we talk about Leonard
the SE second who killed 10 million
Conan which were not taught in schools
by the way crying because they're black
they not even shedding a tear for the 10
million congales or Hitler the 6 million
Jews that he Massac whatever but he gets
upset when one solders die it's bizarre
like that but anyways let's carry on the
fact that a single shot rifle only
allowed for one bullet as a hunter dead
center and that that epitomized to you
uh the care and attention that he put
into his work and he was a beautiful
gunsmith and Craftsman uh all of these
things um and then became a teacher and
was quite a tough disciplinarian you say
here he could be fearsome you know act
acting up in W's class was not the
world's best idea and as a result there
wasn't much trouble there that was
definitely true but but he loved kids
too and he was great with them
and as I was reading all this I was just
thinking wow okay I get it now I get
where Jordan has got all this from there
are so many parts of your dad's
character in you clearly I mean do you
feel that did you when you wrote this
obituary did you did you feel that
really quite
intensely well you know you pointed to
that detail with regards to these rifles
like my father had 300 rifles this was a
real Obsession and he was a very good
shot he was a provincial level shot and
it took me 30 years to figure out why
the hell he collected those guns I don't
think he knew and I told him five years
ago I said dad I figured out why you're
so obsessed with rifles I said it's
because you want to hit the target dead
center with one Shad loved kids Pier is
uh you know really just praising yes
Jordan here and they're both shills
they're both shills for the Israeli
propaganda machine and what's basically
going on here is this the way that he
conducts an interview with other guests
so when he brings on palestin whose
families have been affected does he
begin the interview by saying oh um
Palestinian Ambassador like he's had and
saying basically I know your family has
suffered in the nakat none of that go
straight for the jugular you know this
and that do you condemn Israel do you
condemn
Hamas this just shows you the power
framing how do you frame the discussion
you know humanizing him and right now p
is supposed to be a journalist right
right now the question should be didn't
you say cuz remember appears has
criticized Israel he has not didn't you
say give them hell don't you feel the
same pain that you have for your father
don't you feel for the mothers and the
fathers and the children in Palestine
like what the hell is going on but look
look at how he's completely switched
character yeah yeah yeah it's probo you
cannot make this stuff up it's like it's
like two different people it's a bipolar
Behavior I I feel that Peterson's taken
a battering yeah and through the death
of his father and the reminder about
that death they're trying to bring him
back and they're trying to make peers
look good they're trying to make this is
B basically a propaganda uh a piece a
fine piece of propaganda to bring
Peterson back into this so you know even
if you come across someone as evil as
Hitler and you saw a child's photo of
him or he was nice to a pet EXA somebody
may start sympathizing yeah yeah exactly
that's basically what's going on him
that's what's happening my father was a
tough man and so he was the fire chief
of the local town as well and and
uh the adventure for him was his ability
to Prevail you know and as as you
pointed out the long cabin that he grew
up in was actually Saskatchewan his
parents were pioneers and like the long
cabin that he grew up and still stood
when I was a kid we used to go out there
he was quite sentimentally attached to
it but he was a he was a Pioneer type my
father you know
the so and he was great with little kids
great and he spent a lot of time with me
when I was little a lot and it it made a
huge difference to me you know we we
found a clip this is you actually
interviewing your father uh several
years ago let's take a look at this I
remember driving home with you to na a
number of times and talking the whole
time because you'd never stop asking
questions yeah well hasn't changed much
I think I remember mostly when I was a
little kid reading with you oh yeah yeah
well that was great that was so much fun
I thought
so I can see how moved you are Jordan
understandably I have no remorse for
this man I'm so sorry I'm I'm I'm
obviously that his father passed away in
natural causes by the way natural causes
age of life um just imagine for a second
he talked about him being a child and
his father you know he loved kids Etc
okay no problem imagine somebody comes
to his father's land who's a shooter
who's a hunter and takes over the house
um or tries to harm Jordan Peterson as a
child what do you think his father would
have done shot that person and he's
quite he's precise he said he that one
shot he was very precise with that yes
he put his mind to something would that
man defend his family absolutely his
house his property his honor correct
yeah the same people that are doing that
in Palestine are called what terrorists
and what is Jordan Peterson
saying to those leaders who are carrying
out those Massacre that genocide give
them you can't make this up well I'm
just thinking is this a separate Jordan
Peterson how does one acknowledge him as
a child his connection to his father and
see fathers carrying their blown up
children and you can in the same breath
say give them hell I don't buy man you
are an evil man you are an evil man
absolutely and you know when we're
talking about uh this particular issue
we're talking about things that go back
decades
right and you know there's always this
thing about people misconstruing what
we're saying we're not saying anything
about Hamas we're not saying anything
about any particular group or endorsing
violence what we're saying is look at
your mindset you have such a mindset
that you know people who are coming and
attacking and killing and raping and
pillaging you basically are encouraging
them yes like what kind of Madness is
this and here when it comes to your
father and what happened you're
emotional about it you're sad about like
it all just doesn't make any sense
exactly this guy makes me sick I'll be
honest I don't I have no remorse for you
yes your dad passing away again sorry to
hear that but you as an individual you
crying let me tell you something my
heart hasn't moved a single bit because
you are an evil man so to me I'll be
honest you want to carry I don't want to
watch this guy's face anymore is it
anything you want to watch to be honest
no I
mean this is what it's about I mean when
it comes to us as human beings we have a
moral sense nobody nobody no muslim no
Christian no Jew no atheist no agnostic
reasonable people will come to the
conclusion you shouldn't kill innocent
people you shouldn't kill unarmed people
you shouldn't do these types of things
yet you have a guy who will go and he
knows what the Israeli Israelis have
done in the past he's not an idiot he
knows what they've done in the past he
knows the power that they have and how
weak the other side is they don't have
any air defenses they don't have nothing
and he's basically telling them give
them hell but by his own father he wants
to cry he wants to be emotional not bip
BR tell what it's like it's like those
people who watch Nazi old films right
they forget all the horrors of World War
II even British people and they're like
look at what great orator Hitler was
they they they just look at one little
aspect and they forget everything else
and this is the thing we have to keep in
mind he is fundamentally somebody that
became popular because of a moral issue
he wanted to take a stance against the
trans people right or pronouns or
whatever it was I don't remember but
that was it it was a moral issue he
wanted to stand up freedom of speech and
and what is he doing he's using the
platform that he's been given to promote
the greatest atrocity of our times
exactly and just I Lear on this note is
that like you said his his movement
started with the whole transgender
movement Etc whatever uh those who are
castrating their self so he wanted to
say these children who have been
brainwashed into castrating themselves
uh and in Israel there are snipers
targeting private parts of young boys
yes you can't make this stuff up bro
you're an evil dirt bag yeah that's what
I'm going to say in and brother and
sisters you can see the double stands in
the book The Whole World can see it uh
again that's what we have to say um if
you want us to react to any other videos
every Thursday please do let us know
till next time